what's with the jeans my favorite oh I
can't wish I can understand these jokes
though I don't understand what he's
saying Lots okay it's like Topp Dogg
called it yeah it's a dad these are all
dad joke um I could I'm saying I'm
offering this as a favor I wouldn't
normally do this to most people it's
just cuz you're my wife mm-hmm I can
break down any of these jokes for you
really oh yes
ladies and gentlemen Tom Segura master
okay what would you like to hear that
well joke again which region are we in
again Lancaster Lancaster okay and could
you I mean could you explain the jokes I
just don't should I go back to the last
joke I understand the stand-up comedy
one okay yeah like it sounds like
they're kind of regional references
totally get them okay so go ahead sure
yeah let me just set it up for you
eighteen ninety so the guys from
Southport okay and he's telling that
he's telling them hey it'd be eighty
quid to get into a house around here
eighty quid right and how is it new well
as new as you'll get around here they're
from 1890 so he's just saying everything
here is old as shit sure and super cheap
it's a shitty part of town
okay good can you can you mimic this
accent oh yeah oh yeah yeah okay
no love I was asked to sit down that was
amazing
do you do stand-up comedy no love I was
asked to sit down
this guy's laugh is so funny yeah what a
shitty thing to do to somebody that's
him medium wanted to get on OK as a
master of accents yeah how do you know
well I could just it doesn't matter what
someone's you know any acts that I
couldn't bring not only could i mimic it
also I never have trouble you know
understanding that was amazing yeah it's
just it's like the guy that wrote in
about his teeth he doesn't go to the
dentist for 15 years right his gift is
genetically he's gifted with his mouth
yours is it's all through the ear and
then over yep around here and then yeah
and then it comes out however I wanted
to sounds really good cigarette oh
that's one fag on that train again he's
British
right this is a fact right he's a
cigarette oh right oh yeah you look like
he's selling Michael Caine yeah you just
dip in and out of it region sounds
really can you do Michael Caine for us a
little bit well I love I like a fair
Rupert Smith his name in the in the
movie yeah three runs channels root
rubrics rupprecht rubric
now now rubric yeah yeah is this a bit
are they doing a bit now I think what it
is is this guy's just a shitty hacky
morning guys is he aware is that his bit
he's does he know what he's doing no
it's like yeah yeah it's so good I'm
saying is he playing a part of a shitty
radio oh I see - perfect I don't know I
think he doesn't know I think this guy
really thinks he's rad and funny and
then the colleges Oh Venus shit yeah
it's really really fun it's really good
good lord
yeah man that's so funny I wish would
people would do that to American radio
people I think he might be trolling I
think it might be a troll both the guy
because the guy has posted the guy that
whose name is in the video I mean unless
he didn't put this up he keeps saying
he's a world-class broadcaster
communicator you know I mean so it's
almost like he's he's selling he's in
how good he is so hard that I believe
that he might be right all of us ty
can't pace but are they taiking in pain
nice taking a pace really good that was
really good oh my gosh what is bad jokes
yolo he knows do this opportunity yes do
that I'm gonna have to go yeah you're
gonna don't don't
I'm a famous toast opportunities doubt
no you have to toast opportunity yes
there yeah sexy beast go you gonna
fucking do it
I say no no no don't yes yes yes
they say yes Aikman yes
Hitler what does he say he's again we
hit learn you yes
yes yes yes yeah no I can't do any like
kick some yes you're gonna do it yes yes
you fat shit you fat fucking leathery
fuck you crocodile fucking fat low fat
shit fat motherfucker shit